that's really the problem you're running
into is because you've not run into a 1%
man yet because if Drake did that to you
you would stay with Drake you might not
like it you'd hop up and down and scream
especially if he was emotionally there
for you and y'all were like best friends
and like really really Partners you
wouldn't leave Drake get the [__] out of
here nah you see me right that's
different not because because it's Drake
you know what it is the problem is is is
that you're dating a bomb and you feel
like the the tradeoff is sexual
exclusivity so when you find out he's
cheating on you that's the one thing he
was supposed to give up y's relationship
for you to be with him now you find out
his broke bum ass is cheating on you on
top of that then you're [__] pissed